hi welcome to the view js0 260 tutorial
where we go through a brief description
on what vue.js is what's different about
it why you should learn it and then
implement a project that uses mostly the
features of you that you'll need most of
the time aka the essentials now what is
view views a front-end JavaScript
framework for creating component based
single page applications like the other
major players angular and react we can
use view to write interactive components
each with their data logic and markup
and link them together to create full
web applications multiple components
make up a page and components can be
nested within each other for more
modularity and separation of concerns
they can communicate data up and down
the component hierarchy either locally
using props and events or globally using
a application wide state components can
also share logic stored in dedicated
files known as services considering that
most view developers are people that
migrate from angular and react I'll
assume you have some knowledge on what a
front-end framework is so I'll focus on
what makes view stand out from the
others views considered to be a
framework straight out of the box it has
more features than something like react
not to dis react in any way it's
actually my favorite out of the three
but I think with official complimentary
libraries like view router for routing
vo x4 state management and the view CLI
it provides a better ecosystem
especially for beginners although it has
less tools than angular but that's not
necessarily a good or a bad thing it
depends on the type of project that
you're working on angular is more suited
to complete bigger applications view has
the easiest learning curve out of the
three
unlike angular which is a great
framework but has terrible documentation
in my opinion view actually has amazing
documentation explaining all of its
features with examples that are simple
and easy to understand and apply and it
provides great template syntax that
allows you to use your existing HTML and
CSS skills while giving you access to
great directives that let you write your
markup in a really expressive and
concise manner well I think makes view
shine is the simplicity of it it's
fairly easy to learn you don't have to
learn many new things
like typescript in angular or JSX in
react although you can't use JSX in view
if you wanted provided you add the
babble plug-in that composite view has
brilliant dev tools by far better than
angular augury or react dev tools it
even shows information about view X in
the same extension tab
whereas for react and redux you have to
use two separate extensions for them the
view CLI lets you pick and choose the
features you want to use in your project
before creating it and it allows you to
create certain presets for your projects
if you want to do to create view apps
you need to install the view CLI either
using either NPM or yon I'll repeat what
I said in the angular tutorial that you
need solid JavaScript knowledge you have
to understand how to use fundamental
language features like data structures
loops and conditional expressions async
features like callbacks and promises
higher-order functions like map filter
and sort and be comfortable writing
javascript in general seriously if
you're not yet familiar using javascript
then do not learn a JavaScript framework
yet however if you feel that your
JavaScript is decent then this tutorial
is for you alright enough of the theory
and let's jump to the code or I just
wanted to mention quickly that for this
tutorial we're going to be using this
API that I created a while ago as part
of the AWS lambda and dynamodb tutorial
that I made on this channel I'll put a
link description if you are interested
in that if not you can just follow along
I'll post as well the base URL of the
API that you can use so you can use it
along it's a simple crud API so as you
can see if I send a get request to this
URL and to slash posts it gets me a list
of posts sorted by created ad and if I
send a post request to the slash post
route and just say oh no just some
gibberish and hits and will actually
persist this post on the database and
then I can take this ID as well
and send a put request to the slash post
slash the ID of that post and edit it
and let's say edited here and say editor
here and I'll stand and it will actually
edit that post
a problem here because because of the
white space yeah it will actually edit
that post and then give me back that
post you can actually do can as well
delete and we can do slash post slash
any number and you will limit the number
of posts by that number so we did for
now we got four alright so it's
identical to the adjacent placeholder
API except in this one the data actually
persists and in the Jason placeholder it
doesn't you can use that as well if you
want alright so here on my desktop I
would usually use the git bash tool but
because of the interactive mode there's
it doesn't work so I'm just gonna use a
traditional command line I'm gonna see
the into my desktop and here make sure
you have the view CLI installed you can
check by running view - - version like
this and I have 3.5 installed so I have
it installed and now I can do a view
create and let's call this view -
starter and now the CLI - is gonna ask
me to choose a preset usually I've got
the default but I just want to show you
the other option so you can manually
select features how would you usually
pick the CSS process pre-processors
because i prefer using sass and i would
maybe put the router but i want to show
you how to set it up yourself and not
have a boiler plated I'm just gonna
press enter here you can press space if
you want to select any of these features
I'm just gonna press ENTER for now I'm
gonna select this es lint error
prevention and say lint on safe and here
asks you where you want this Babel
configuration and the other conflict to
go
I want to want it to go in dedicated
files because otherwise it's gonna make
the package.json bloated here it's gonna
ask me if I want to save this preset I'm
gonna say no and now it's gonna actually
install the packages and create a
boilerplate for our project it's gonna
take a while so I'll be back once it's
done alright now that it's done
installing we can see the Intuit so say
CD View starter and here I'll open it
using vs code so just run code dot let
me close this window so this is our
project so we get a cup
of config files and we get a
package.json file and here we have a
couple of scripts our main one that
we'll be using is the serf to just serve
it and then later we'll use build to
build it out and here we have
dependencies or the view and our a
couple of dev dependencies nothing fancy
so if you open up the source folder
right here we have our main j/s so here
we're important view and then we our
initiate initializing a new view
instance and telling it to mount our app
in instead of the div with the ID up so
you go to the public folder to the
index.html this is where our app will go
this div right here will be replaced by
our application so here I'll just change
the title show you you can change the
title here let's say view tutorial and
here let's go back to the source and
inside the source let's go to the app
view file I'll save this and all the
view components are dot view files and
you can in vs code you can install this
extension called virtual write this one
and it will properly highlight your
syntax your view syntax so that you can
you know actually write these files
otherwise they will be all in one color
so here this is our main app right here
you can see we have a div and inside of
here we're using another component
called hello world that comes already
created which is right here in the
components folder and we can use
components by just importing them and
adding them to this components object
and then here just using that tag that
select the tag and every view component
has a template tag this is where our you
know markup goes our HTML markup and we
have a script tag where our logic goes
our JavaScript logic and we optionally
have a style tag to style this component
this can be global and it can be local
as well if you add the scoped directive
to it it will only apply to this
component all right let's change a
couple of things I'm actually going to
delete this hello world and let's delete
all of this
right here I'll just put a head of two
for now saying up I'm gonna remove this
import because this file no longer
exists and I'm gonna remove this
components object and remove this
styling and let's actually start our app
how open the command line terminal and
say npm run serve alright now that it's
compiled and running we can control
click on here and it's serving on
localhost 8080 so this is our app it
just says up right now nothing much
let's actually install materialise for
this I'm going to use materialized and
we can you can later use something like
beautify but for now I just want to use
the CSS library to implement Google
material design styling so we can go to
get started on the materialized CSS comm
page and here I'll just grab this
command copy it and let's go to the
terminal I'm gonna open a different
window and paste that command and on top
of materialized I want to install the
view router right now so we can set up
some routes view router and I'm just I'm
gonna create two components I mean two
pages the about page and the home page
the about page is just created just for
me to demonstrate to you how the router
works so I'm gonna create them while the
router is being installed here is we
create a folder I'll call this views
because this is a convention in view
that you would your pages will go into
the views folder and your components
that make up your page will go to the
components folder so here and the views
folder I'll create a new file actually
new file and I'll call this home view
like this I'm going to create another
one not a folder a file call this about
the view and here in the components I'm
gonna create two new files one is navbar
dot view and the other one we'll use
later or call this post form the view
alright I'll close everything and let's
actually go to the documentation go to
components I want to put the navbar on
top of our page so
go to Napa and just grab this knife tug
right here let's go back to our project
and here in the nav bar dot view we have
to say template press tab and inside of
the template we paste this so this is
now our component we don't need to have
a script or a style and here this is our
nav bar I'm going to change the logo
title to view tutorial tutorial and here
I'll remove one of these links and leave
just to one we'll say home and one will
say about and for now I'm gonna leave
these eight reps as hash but when we
implement the router and these are
actually gonna go somewhere so let's
actually use this component so here in
the app let's import it first so in the
script and say import navbar from and
from the same level components slash
navbar actually gonna close the terminal
window and here inside of the our export
tag here and set our script we need to
actually add again that components
object and inside that object we give it
all the components that we want to use
and for now it's just gonna be the nav
bar once I actually I forgot to import
materialized CSS so let's do that so
here in our app we can you can as well
import it in the index.html but I prefer
doing it on the app view file alright so
here we'll say import and we go back one
level and we go to node underscore
modules modules slash materialize our
CSS slash dist / CSS / materialize -
actually no - just materialized min dot
CSS I'm gonna copy all of this and paste
it one more time and now we need the
JavaScript so here we'll say JavaScript
and here we'll say materialized is
actually not Mindo jeaious
all right so let's save everything and
make sure there's no errors there isn't
let's go to our app right here let's
refresh it some reason nutbar is not
working all right
there's no errors but oh I forgot to
actually put it in the template so here
we'll say navbar like this self closing
tag actually everything needs to be
under one component in the template so
I'll just wrap everything in a div and
here I'll say now bar and headed to up
and we can see we have our nav bar it
has two links but these links don't go
anywhere yet and we have our app header
actually I want these buttons to come a
bit inside like closer to the middle so
here in the nav bar view I'm gonna wrap
everything inside of here within a
container so I say div the class of
container which is a materialized class
so here so it's up to here all of this
you will actually not do you well this
whole yeah actually until here I
confused myself for a second so here we
close that div we save it formats and if
we go back to our app there we go we get
our buttons pushed a bit in alright
let's go back to the app view let's set
up our router so that we can go to our
about and home pages so we can actually
put all of the code of the router here
but maybe you'll have a lot of routes so
it's better to separate it into its own
file
so here in the source folder I'm gonna
create a new file call it router
jeaious and here I'll import a couple of
things so here we'll import view from
view and on port router from you can
name anything this default is the
default export from view let's go -
router and here we need to import our
views our pages so it will say import
she's not from import about from views
oops views slash about dot view remember
to add the dot view to every component
you import because they're not
JavaScript files unlike react so here
we'll say I tapped react import home
from views slash home thought view now
we need to set up our routes but first
we need to tell view to use the router
so we need to save you don't use and
this you used to tell view to use any of
the plugins that you want so here our
plugin is the actual router so we'll
just say this and here we need to export
our router will say export
default new router and this takes a
couple of options and here we'll say
mode and we'll give it a value of
history because otherwise you're the
default is the hash mode which adds the
hash to the URL I don't like that will
put mode history and here we need to
setup our routes so let's say routes
route and it's gonna be an array and
it's gonna have objects for each one
will have a path so this is gonna be the
home page so I'm just gonna say slash
and the we need a component and this is
this will be the home component and we
can have like name and some other
properties but these are the essential
ones let's create another one for the
about so we'll say path is slash about
and component is about save our file for
the router to work we need to add it
here in the main chest in this
instantiation call and we need to import
it so let's say import
router run the same level router like
this and here we need to pass it to this
new view call as the first argument and
so router and put comma
so now the router is actually
implemented but we need to as well go to
the app view
here instead of this up header actually
I'm gonna wrap everything in a container
it's a dock container tap and here we
need to put the router view component or
like selector so this will tell view
that this this is where we want our mark
up from the router to go so these are
our pages we'll go here let's put some
content in our pages so that we can tell
the difference between them so here
we'll say template and here for now I'm
Justin and I'm gonna say header 3 of
home page I'm going to copy this and go
to the about page and just say about
page all right let's save everything and
let's go to our app alright so now we
have home on the slash of type slash
we have a container everything is pushed
to the middle
if we click about it doesn't go to the
about page oh I know why actually Oh
silly me yeah in the nav bar these are
still like normal anchor tags we need to
replace these with router links so here
instead of the a tag here let's control
D so you select both the a tags and
replace this with router - link and here
instead of href it's gonna be a property
called attribute called - this is gonna
be - slash and here do the same replace
the anchor tag actually it just oops
this no select this and this and here
let's say router link instead of HR
after hash we will go to slash about we
need to replace this as well so this
will be a router link and still have a
to attribute to slash and change this as
well - router link let's save let's go
to our app and now work so if I go to
about it goes to slash about and we see
the about page and the home as well and
this is well as the home page
alright cool now we're done with the
naba so we can close this and we're
actually not going to
do anything here as well in the main and
the router so we can close these and now
let's actually start working on our
homepage and let's start to fetch the
data from our back-end and show it or
show all the posts on our home page for
this I'm actually going to install Axios
we don't have to we can use fetch but I
prefer using Axios because it removes on
get requests and on actually hope
requests it removes that step of having
to call resto JSON and it has some extra
features that will be more in handy in
bigger applications all right so now
that we have
Axios installed here in the home you can
remove this header I'm going to put a
row so let's say don't row and here I
want to show all the posts but first we
need to fetch them so we could actually
in our script here we can fetch them
here but since we're gonna need this
logic shared between components
potentially so we could abstract all of
the data manipulation in one file and
make it into a service so here in the
source folder I'm going to create a new
file I'm gonna call this post service
jeaious and like the in the angular
tutorial we put everything in the
service will do the same here so we'll
put new here we need to import x-axis so
in for Axios oops
Axios from Axios and here we need to put
our our base URL constant so it will say
Const base or API base URL this is in
the description I'm gonna grab this from
the side and paste it here alright so
here we'll say export oops export
default and this is gonna be a class and
we'll call this post service and here
we'll have our methods or here we'll
have the first method we'll be getting
all posts let's call this get all posts
and it won't take anything and it will
return
Axios but get
and here we'll pass the base URL so API
actually we need to concatenate on it so
let's do backticks and for dollar sign
curly braces and say api base URL slash
posts like this so this will return the
Axios promise of getting api base URL
slash posts so that we can get it from
the home page we can access that and
then show the data so here in the home
view file we'll create a script tag and
inside of here in the default export
let's give this a name and say home and
here inside of the script tag I'll say
import we'll import that service or
import post service from go back one
level to post service like this and we
need to since this is a class we need to
instantiate an instance of it so we'll
say Const post service camel case like
this with the lower case P we'll say
equals new post service like this call
it so that we can create an instance we
can use that and now let's actually
start to create to bring our data so
here inside of our component we'll add
another property called data like this
as a data like this is a function and
data think of it as the state like if
you if you come from react this is
basically our component state this is
where we put all our data for this
component so here we'll have a an array
of posts so say posts and you wish this
will be initially an empty array and
will populate it with our data so we
need to populate this post array once
our component is created so for this
we'll use a lifecycle method called
created so call created like this as a
function you can do like this as an as a
property and then say function but the
shorthand syntax which is more useful to
just call it like this pass like a
function and inside of here we need by
the way this is a life
there's four main methods if you go to
the view documentation there's a cool
graph or diagram showing you how these
methods work there is
first there's the created and then
there's mounted and there's updated once
the component is updated and then
there's destroyed once it's destroyed
and there is the ones that are
in-between them if you come from react
this is kind of similar to well not kind
of actually exactly the same as
component did mount component that
update and component will will mount etc
so in the created now we need to reach
out to our service and actually get our
data so here we'll actually use our this
instance at this post service instance
and say post service dot and we need to
call this method get all posts that we
created and this returns a promise so we
need to change then and here when we get
our result we need to actually you know
don't need a block we just need one call
and we need to say this dot posts I
actually have to put it in a block that
we can do other stuff so we'll say this
top posts and now because this post is
in this class and any of this these data
properties here we refer to them with
this dot and then we put the name of
that so we can access it and unlike
react you don't need to call at this dot
state that's this set State or something
you can mutate them directly and that
will be done in the in the behind the
scenes which is quite neat I find that
it reduces the amount of code that we
have to write so here we'll say this dot
posts equals because this is Axios our
data is stored in a in a object called
data that's inside of the response so
we'll say this top post equals response
dot data and here I want to console our
posts just to make sure that we actually
got them so let's say console dot log
actually not post this or post this no
there's not posts like this and of
course this can fail so we need to say
that catch error and if we have an error
we need to console dot or that error
all right let's save everything let's
make sure it compiles successfully let's
go to
she opened another one so here there's
an error data function should return an
object yeah okay yeah inside of the data
here we need to return an object so let
me cut this you need to say return yeah
so inside of this object we say post
like this yeah this should fix it all
right we have another error and no we
don't actually
so we have our data right here oops my
voice is cracking all right so we have
our data this is the latest post that we
added earlier the edited one and we have
all the other posts cool so we're
actually getting our data successfully
let's now actually show it in the markup
let me actually close this terminal
windows take an unnecessary space so
here inside of this row I'm gonna say
create another div so call which is
column dot s6 which means it will take
half of this screen width so here in the
in here what I want to put is I wanna
put for each post I want to put a card
with all the the data that relates to
that post so here we'll say dot card
oops card like this but we need to tell
view that we want to iterate through our
posts array and for each one we need to
show this card so inside of this div
right here we're not inside the div
inside of the the attributes of the div
we need to put this directive called V
for : and then actually not :
equals and now we give it the expression
that tells it to loop in in whatever
array we wanted to loop through so here
we wanted to loop in posts and here
actually we can access so with
parentheses and say post and I want I
want the index as well because we need
it like this and say in posts and now it
knows that this posts is this posts
right here and it's given us a red
squiggly because we need to give it a
key a unique key just like it's like if
you worked with react each element in an
iterator needs a unique key so here
action we need to bind another property
so here we'll use
another director directive called V bind
and this is what you used to bind any
value from the component to some data in
in the markup or to pass it as a prop to
a component so here's a V bind : say
item equals and I want to bind it to the
post so it knows what the item of this
div is and here we want to bind another
property and by the way there's a
shorthand shorthand notation for V bind
is just : like this so let's say : index
right here the property of index I'm
gonna give it the index this is why I
obtained I got it from here so we'll
just say index like this and now we need
to bind the key so we'll say : key
equals it will be post ID because I know
we have IDs for each post and they are
unique so we can use that alright so now
for each post in our post it's gonna
create this of course when we need to
put more stuff here so inside of the
card we need to put a card the hash
content not hash - and this is by the
way this materialized stuff and here I
want to put the title first I'm gonna
call it's gonna be a paragraph so
paragraph with a class card title and
inside of here now we want to access the
title property inside of post and put it
here and for this we're gonna use a
string interpolation kind of like
angular if you used it this is why I
like about react action about vo rather
it's got some really cool features from
angular and really cool features from
react and emerges both of them so here
we'll say post dot title and this is a
string interpolation but as well you can
have like JavaScript expressions here
you can have anything you can put if I
do like this for example I don't know to
uppercase and it will actually turn into
uppercase so you can write JavaScript
inside of here but it's better to write
it inside of the script tag all right so
let's put the created a date so here I'm
gonna say P dot time stamp
because I know I'm gonna style this
later and here I'll put post-doc created
at like this and let's put the body of
the post so he will have a normal
paragraph yeah we'll put a string
interpolation so double curly braces and
we say post dot body like this and after
the content I want to add another
section dot card action and here I'll
put two buttons one to edit the post and
want to delete the post of course
they're not gonna do anything right now
but we'll just put them as dummy buttons
for now so here this link will go no
we're just gonna have a hash for an href
and here we'll have have it say edit I'm
gonna copy this and here put it and have
it say delete that's I'm gonna give this
a class because I want to make this red
class of delete
BTN like this let's go down to the
script tag and style this delete button
the style tag which we don't have so
let's say style and it's out here scoped
because we don't need these styles
outside and we can just scoped them to
this component and here I'll say dot
delete oops delete - button and for that
I'm gonna give it a color of red and
save everything and let's go to our app
and there we go so we get our data we
get all our posts each of them has its
own card and we have these
like this the title they created and the
body of the post but this button is not
red actually so inspector that's not
applying because we need to be more
specific so card the card action but
actually I don't want a style the other
one red as well but I'm just gonna say
important for now important let's save
let's go back yeah it's red now see I
wanna I want to put this date closer to
the title and put this body a bit
further away and make this date grey so
that it doesn't attract too much
attention so here inside of this style
where is it Scott title so here I'll say
card but card content dot card title and
I'm gonna give this a margin bottom of
zero and here I'm going to copy this
here instead of cod title I'm gonna have
the paragraph dot time stamp and this
will have a color of gray color hash
nine nine nine and a margin bottom say
ten pixels it's safe let's go back cool
this looks much better
all right let's go back to our app let's
now add a forum for adding posts so here
at the top of our template here let's
create another row so doc the row and
inside of here I'll put Oh actually
everything here needs to wrap to be
wrapped in one components or a div
I'll copy the closing tag and underneath
here we'll put it like that
so now it's not compare complaining
anymore so inside of this row I'm gonna
put a call as six like this and here
this is where our form goes so I can
just put a comment and say form we could
actually put our form here but it's
better to put it in its own component so
we'll have two smaller components
instead of one big one oh yeah of course
we already created that component I
forgot so here I'll say post post form
like this and close the tab and let's
import that component so here we need to
say import post form from we go back one
level and we go into components and we
get post form all right and we need to
as well declare it in the components
array here so we need to say or
components object here inside of that
object we need to say post
form and actually here we need to say
dot view forgot that all right we need
to put a comma here and now let's go to
that post form and actually create this
form here we'll say template and by the
way using Vitter veto or whatever we can
say scaffold and you will create create
all of this which is cool so inside the
template we need our forms will say form
and this will not have an action but the
way I wanted to 2b is that I want to
have later a boolean variable of loading
and if it's not loading it will show the
form and if it's loading I wanted to
show like later a lot of loading spinner
so I'll give this a directive called V
if and this takes say condition and if
this condition is true it will render
this component if it's not a component I
mean this element if it's not it's not
going to render it and there's a
different component there's a different
directive called V show which is
different which is gonna if it's if it's
false it's you know it's gonna have it
but with a display of false we're gonna
use V if and we'll say if not loading
which we haven't created yet but we will
I'm gonna give this a class of form to
style it later and here we want to give
it the onset the submit event so here
we'll say we'll use another directive
called V on and this will take a an
event so the event will be the submit
event and we need to give it actually
what the method will execute on when
this event happens and we'll call this
own submit and we'll create this in a
bit and here we'll say put our first
input so dot input field and again this
is materialized CSS classes here we'll
have will have two two inputs one for
the title of the post and one for the
body so here we'll have a label for
title and you will say title like this
and we'll have an input and this will be
of type text and we're gonna have a
couple of things here so indent like
this
and here what I want to do is I want to
give it a name call it a title and now
we want to bind this input to a value in
our component in our state and to do
this we need to say v-model its
directive and this is a two-way binding
so if the input changes the variable
inside of our component changes and if
that variable value changes the input
value as well changes so it's a two-way
binding here we'll say title this is our
V model and we need to give this a class
oops class of validate so that we will
have a helper text underneath and if
there's an error or there's a valid
state it will show that help helper text
here will say span with the class of
helper - text and here we'll have a
property called data error or attribute
data error and this is in case we have
an error this will show in red and it
will show the text as that's written
inside of this attribute so for the
title that our error text will say title
must not be empty because that's what
we're handling it being empty so let's
close this tags span and so this by
default will not show unless this input
has the class of invalid and we'll do
the validation ourselves
so here I'll copy this whole div this
input field paste it and we'll have here
the bodies or body labels for the body
that the name the text on the label will
say body type is text the name is body
the v-model is well is body and the
error here we'll say body must not be
empty and here we need to add the submit
button so here we'll have a button oops
button with the type of submit like this
press tab and here we need to give it a
couple of classes to have styling I'm
gonna give it the waves effect class and
waves
light and BTN and here it will say ad
all right so that's our markup now let's
go to our script here we'll give the
same name so name and the value will be
post form and here we need our data so
data the function like this and we say
return and we return this object so what
we have we have the loading we have and
our two models title and body so loading
which by default will be false and we'll
have our title by default
initially will be an empty string and
the body initially would be an empty
string as well now let's actually handle
the submission or actually let's let's
see our what our form looks like first
and then see from there alright there's
no errors saved all files let's go to
our app yeah alright so our form looks
cool when I actually give it some margin
so that it's pressed a bit to the middle
so here let's go to our file here in
this style will say form I'm gonna give
it a margin 50 pixels let's save all
right looks better like this it's open
up the dev tools make sure that there's
no errors actually there is yeah just
complains that we don't have the on
submit method because we actually don't
yet so let's create it inside of our
components our custom methods are kept
inside of one object called methods so
we say methods like this and now here we
can put all the methods that we want for
our component of course now we need to
create the on submit method and here we
can pass it an event and we can say
event.preventdefault so that the the
page doesn't reload but we can also use
these things called modifiers so right
here on submit we can say dot and chain
modifiers which do certain things on
each event and one modifier for the
submit event is the
prevent which by defaults prevent by
default runs event.preventdefault
without us having to type that in our
code and by the way shorthand notation
for V on would be the ad so this ad
submit and this will work as well and it
gives you some cool intelligence on what
events that you can use if you press
control space alright so let's go here
in our on submit now let's handle the
submission and here we'll say first
thing this dot loading equals true
because now we're going to communicate
to our server and let's not worry about
validation for now let's try to send
this post to our server but first we
need to actually create that method in
the post service so here in the post
service I'm gonna create a method called
write post which will actually handle
both the post and the put requests we'll
take a post and here we'll say if post
dot ID out so the way this write post I
put it to work is that we send it a post
and if the post has an ID that means we
are editing this post because this post
already exists and has an ID but if it
doesn't that means this is a new post so
I actually use the post the post method
add slash post and and create a new post
so here if it has an ID
we're actually editing a post so we want
to say return
Axios oops Axios dot put and this will
be two so we do backticks we put we need
to put our api base URL
well actually instead of putting it all
the time we could what can we do
actually what we can do is we can say
here we can say Axios told defaults
defaults like this dot base URL equals
and we'll give it this URL and each time
we do an Axios request we send an HTTP
request through Axios it's gonna use
this as the base URL so here in the gate
actually we need to get rid of this we
no longer need that we can just
to slash posts and this can be just
normal you know it doesn't have to be
back ticks and here we'll say so we
remove that base URL we don't need that
and we'll say it will be to slash post
slash and here we'll do a variable and
we'll say post dot ID so this is a put
request so it needs a body and the body
will be the post itself else if it
doesn't have an ID so we're creating a
new post so we're here will here we'll
say return
Axios dot post and this will be 2 slash
post and you will have the post itself
as the body of the request well while
we're here let's actually create the
other methods and not open this file
again here I'll put another method
called get posts which gets post with a
limit so the number of posts so here
we'll say we need to pass it the number
of posts and here we'll say return if
you remember from the API we need to
send a request to slash posts a slash a
number so
Axios don't get back ticks slash posts
slash don't assign curly brace and we
put that number argument right here and
we have one oops we have one more to
create which is the delete post which
will take an ID of a post and and send a
request to delete it so say return
Axios dot delete and this will be 2
slash so curly backticks slash posts not
supposed to actually just post / post
and here we put a variable that ID all
right so we're done with the post
service we can save this and close it
forever
and here in our submit we need to reach
this right post and send this post and
actually first we need to import the
service so here we'll say import post
service from we go back one level post
service we need to instantiate and
so we'll say Const post-service
equals new post oops
service so this like this and here let's
form our post so we'll say constants
Const post equals this will be will have
a title which will be remember this this
v-model
binds the value of the input here to the
motor to the data here in our state or
in our data and if it changes this
changes as well automatically so we can
just give the values of these once the
form is submitted so the title will be
this dot title and the body will be this
dot body what do you like this and now
we actually send our request so say post
service dot what is it write write post
call in Tennyson's right there and we
pass it the post and here we'll say dot
then because that returns an Axios
promise and then if you get a response
then let's get our post from that
response so oh yeah a respond we can
just console.log it for now so let's
console dot log and our rest data and
you need to say touches well in case
there's an error somehow and we'll say
console dot error the error all right
let's say make sure we don't have any
errors we don't cool all right let's go
to our app it's open the console okay
there are a couple of those or this
refresh maybe not yeah they were from
last time
all right so here we need to type let's
say a new post oops
new post from view and view is really
cool
let's click add the form goes away
always because of the loading that's why
it goes away all right so we get this
from nars
server that a post is created got an ID
and everything but of course it's not
added because we haven't added the logic
to add it here so let's refresh there we
go when we refresh we get the new data
updated and we get our post let's fix
that the form goes away so here once we
get the data back we need to set the
loading to false so we'll get our
loading equals false so that we get our
form back let's go to our app refresh
let's put some gibberish click Add cool
it comes back but it still got the
values if we refresh we get we'll get
that gibberish was submitted cool but we
need to reset the form once it's
submitted actually the way we can do
that we can just reset our data so here
we'll say this body so this top body
equals an empty string again and this
dot title equals an empty string and
when the form goes away I want to put
the loading the loading thing you know
you call it where is it it's right yeah
the preloader
yeah this the indeterminate what is a
progress bar I guess yeah so I'll just
copy this and let's go to the bottom
here under our form we'll put it put
that here and instead of saying V if we
can use another directive V else if and
we'll pass it the loading can use VF as
well here but V else if works with this
one as well so it doesnt trigger both of
them so it's better for performance that
it's a tiny bit but whatever so if we're
loading we need we're gonna see this now
and our form should reset because we
reset those values to an empty string so
let's go to our app let me close
everything here let's reload and then if
I send some gibberish again we see that
loading for a second and the form is
back and the form is reset to no data
cool I want to style this actually and
by the way we can open and if you want
to see that because the loading
too fast you want to see the loading bar
and stylet we can go or is the view
developer tools okay I don't have it
installed on somehow ok view dev tools
install that add to Chrome I thought I
had it okay I had to restart chrome for
the extension to actually work so this
is the dev tools which is pretty cool we
see our component tree right here so our
app and this is our home component and
we can see our data right here so this
is all our posts and so if we dig deeper
into the post form we can see the
loading we can set this to true so true
and we'll get that bar back alright so I
want this bar to actually be centered in
the middle a little bit so I'll give it
some margin so let's go back to our post
forum and here in this critter in the
style I'm gonna target the progress
class so the progress and give it some
margin so I'll give it margin on the top
and bottom of 100 and on left and right
of zero so it's safe let's go back there
we go so start properly now if you go to
the dev tools again and put the loading
again to true we see that loading bar is
in the middle all right cool let's now
what do we do now let's put yeah let's
validate our form in case because if now
right now if we have empty fields and we
hit sound it actually attempts to send
even though there will be errors because
there will be server validation errors
all right let's go here instead of
putting everything in the on submit
let's create a separate method for this
inside of methods I'm gonna create
another one called valid phone and here
what I want to do I'm gonna say actually
I'm gonna add another another variable
state variable here called errors oops
errors and it's gonna be an empty object
for now and here I'll say this stop
errors equals an empty object
here we'll say this now I know this
looks weird that I'm doing this again
given an empty object value again but
this works is that because the way this
works is that if another if we lose an
error I want to reset it and whenever we
check again so that we don't see an
error even though a field is valid I
don't know if that makes sense but it
does work all right so here I'll check
the fields so first I will check the
title and we need to change our trim so
that it removes the white spaces here
I'll say if title dot trim equals an
empty string then we need to add an
error so we'll say this dot oops
like this this not earth dot title
equals and we'll say title I sure don't
think the error is matter yeah because
it doesn't matter I think because this
will show instead of this all right
let's a test I'm just gonna say title
here so here I'm saying if this dot body
dot trim equals an empty string and so
here we'll say this dot Earth but body
equals soon say body for now don't think
these texts matter just just the fact
that they have a value matters and here
I want to say if object dot keys and
pass this dot errors and unchanged
length so if the length of this array or
object rather of the number of keys is
bigger than zero that means we have some
errors so we return false that means our
form is not valid else return return
true else if we don't have any errors
that means the the form is valid so we
return true so here at the top of the on
submit what we need to say is after the
loading I'm going to say if and we need
we can access this method again by
saying this dot so here we'll say if
this dot valid phone
so and we call it like that azzam
because it's a method we'll say this
the loading equals false and we'll say
return so it stops it doesn't carry on
else we continue or actually know if
this stop valid if not this valid form
because if it's valid we actually want
to do the rest if it's not valid we stop
loading and we return that means none of
this executes all right so let's save
and let's see okay so the fields are
empty click Add alright so we don't get
the errors the phone doesn't submit but
we don't get the earth interesting well
actually yeah what am I saying
I need to give these because the way it
works if I inspect this so this input if
I change the class of the input to
invalid oops
invalid the oh my god all right so this
will show now alright so if I save you
see that span is now visible and you see
that error that title must not be empty
alright so actually we need to change
the class in case we have an error so
here in the class we can do some binding
and here for the class it's gonna be
actually a bound property so we add a
colon in front of it
and here it's gonna be like an
expression like this so we put the
square braces square brackets and here
we'll say errors dot title so this is a
ternary operator so if this is the case
it's a question mark
so if we have errors title then this
should be invalid this should have the
class of invalid
let me make this wraparound else
so colon else if we don't have then you
should just have the class of validate
all right so let's copy this class and
go here for the other input here for the
body
so if we have errors dot body then we
set it to invalid else it's validate all
right let's save and let's go back let's
refresh and now if I submit I should get
errors for both of them all right so I
submit there we go we get errors so if I
some gibberish here and click Add there
we go so that error is gone but we still
need to put this if I put some gibberish
here as well click Add it's added but of
course we're not adding it here because
if we we have to refresh and see our
data now we can as well call again get
get posts but that's not efficient
because that way we send two requests to
our server so what we need to do we need
to send this post using view and just
add it manually in our front-end alright
so let's go to our app here so here once
it's submitted we want to send an event
that this once it's successful want to
send an event and communicate to the
home page that you need to add this post
to your posts array right here so here
we'll use an API method called so we'll
do this thought dollar dollar sign and
we have access to a couple of methods
and name space is given by view and
we'll use the emit one and this here we
need to pass it the event name so the
event name I'll call it what post
created because remember that here we
ran the block that means the post has
been created successfully and now we
need to pass some data which is going to
be the post so now we need to go to our
home component and we need to catch this
event and handle it so here I'm going to
can catch it from anywhere but it's more
appropriate to put it in the forum so
here we'll say - say V on but shorthand
we can just say at so at and we need to
give it the event which was called post
created and now we need to tell it what
to execute once once this event is is
triggered or emitted so here we'll say
call it add post and now let's create
this outpost so right here in we need to
create a methods okay I'm gonna put it
on top of here so methods object let's
put a comma here let's create this add
post method and you will take the post
because this is passed through calling
the event and here we'll just say this
don't posts and we want to add it to the
end because this is an
post so we will use the unchipped method
the JavaScript one shift and pass it
this post
alright let's save all files and so now
what's happening is that when we send
the post and when we send it to our
server and we get a successful response
we emit an event called post created
with this post that we have formed here
and now in the home we catch this event
right here and once that event occurs or
is emitted this add post is executed and
then this outpost adds that post that
was caught here to the post array all
right so now if we add some gibberish
new gibberish is that how you spell
gibberish I don't know just copy it here
add here and there we go it's actually
added on our front end and if we refresh
it's the same that's actually that's the
data that we got from our server
actually is it Oh actually I made a
mistake we need to send the post that we
got back from the server because that
contains the created add the one we have
doesn't contain the created add so here
let's go back to our post form so here
what we emit is actually going to emit
res dot data or or instead let's put
that you know let's put constant post we
already have that anyway it's just
sending res dot data remove this
console.log yeah this should this should
work properly now let's refresh send
some gibberish again there we go we get
the one from the server so that we get
the created art as well all right let's
start to wire these buttons so here for
the right where are the buttons actually
not there in home so here for the
buttons for the Edit we'll say at click
so once this button is clicked we need
to trigger the call it edit post and
we'll pass it this post so remember we
have this post through the for directive
and here for the delete we say add click
we will trigger delete
post and we'll pass it post dot ID so
here in the methods let's create those
so the Edit post which for now I'm just
gonna say console oops console dot log
post and here for the delete post so ID
we need to reach out for to our service
and delete this post so I say post
service dot delete post and we pass it
this ID and this returns a promise so we
need to say dot then we have no results
so we can just leave those that without
an argument and we just console console
dot log post delete it
[ __ ] type you say don't catch you
have an error just console dot error
error like this
all right let's save all of that and
let's go back let's refresh put up the
console and here if we press delete
right here it says post deleted all we
need to remove it actually from the
array but if we refresh that gibberish
is deleted so we can actually just
delete all of these
select on all delete on all of them now
they're actually all deleted all right
but we need to actually manually remove
them using view from here so what we
need to do here in the where's the
delete post once they've been
successfully deleted from the server we
need to change our post so we need to
say this top post equals the stop posts
dot filter and here the filter takes a
what we call a callback and this
callback is we leave only elements with
this condition and the condition will be
post where post ID does not equal this
ID so we only leave the ones that don't
have this ID
ka we just removed the one that has this
ID so let's save let's go back to our
app let's refresh make sure we don't
have any errors we don't - click delete
here now that post is gone from the
front end as well alright cool
so before we work on the Edit I want to
add a post limiter right here and input
to limit the number of posts in our page
so let's go up here in the home so
actually next to the forum here we need
to put another call give it s 3 width
and here we'll say put some text say
limit number of posts here we'll put an
input the type of number and the name I
don't think we need the name attribute I
just use it as a it's just a habit so
here we'll say V model equal is call
this post limit and let's create this
post limit so here in our data let's say
post limit
I'll give it a default value of 5 and
here let's create a method actually we
need to add a button to trigger this
here will say button and you say add
click so once this is clicked we need to
call a method called set limit like this
let's give this a class of waves effect
and waves light and BTN and this will
say set and why that tag didn't close
all right let's go here let's create
this set limit so set limit now we need
to reach to our post service so here
we'll say post service dot unity is that
get posts method and we pass it the post
limit so this the post post limit like
this it's returned the promise so we say
then
and if we get when we get our response
we just need to say this dot posts
equals this response so response data
and the catch
we say console dot error error all right
I think this is it let's save let's go
to our app I want to give this some
margin as well I'm just gonna use some
inline styling for now you'll say style
equals margin 50 pixels it's safe there
we go so we get our limiter let's say I
want only to click set cool we can only
to I'm 1 3 what is this no do i click
sorry click click 3 we get 3 as well so
get the latest 3 cool now if we refresh
we only get all of them and of course we
put like a massive number what is
happening but a massive number we get
all of them anyway alright so I want to
work on the edit now so the way it works
is that I want to when I click Edit I
want here this form to be filled with
the details of that post I clicked edit
and then when we click again add it will
edit that post alone so here we will
actually pass this post down to our post
form so what we need to do we need to
add another variable here call it
editing post and we'll give it a value
of null initially and in the Edit post
where is the edit post here we just say
this dot editing post equals this post
that we clicked and now we need to pass
it to our forum so here we'll say
v-model or actually just like :
shorthand syntax call it the same
editing post equals editing post all
right so we now we pass it to our post
forum as a prop so let's go to our post
form and for us to use props in view we
need to actually declare a props
property and this can be an array and
you pass it the names of the props you
receiving but preferably you put an
object
so that you can use typing as well to
prop typing and you'll say so I want to
receive editing post and this will be of
type object so this is a better practice
than using the strings in an array so
now that we're receiving this what I
want to do is that I want to listen to
change this to this editing post so
whenever this prop changes because by
default we don't have this prop so I
want to that when we get this prop to
trigger that we filled our form with the
data from that post so here we're gonna
use another another thing where are we
actually what is this
so under so under the methods here we
use something else called watch which
watches for changes in our props and
here we could have methods which have
the same name as our variables in our
state so if for example if I wanted to
listen to changes in our for our editing
post prop or for the loading for example
I would say loading and then do
something so I want to listen to changes
in the editing post prop so I'll copy
that and here in the watch I'll paste
that and this will take the post that we
that we got passed down so now this is
our object whenever that changes there
are the editing post this will get
triggered so if it changes we need to
save this dot title so we need to put
our input model to be the same the data
in our inputs to be the same as that
post that we're trying to edit so we'll
say this dot title equals post dot title
and this dot body equals post dot body
alright let's save everything and let's
check if that's working so let's refresh
if we click Edit on this one cool we get
edited but yeah this I don't know that
the label doesn't activate once if we do
this so you see if I click on this one
it's editing this one for clicking it's
editing this one actually let's make it
so that if we're in editing mode this
changes from add to
so so this button needs to have a
conditional value here here we'll say
check for this editing or actually oh
actually here I'll add another property
because we need it actually underneath
the body I'll say ID and this by default
will be no because we need the ID when
we sent it to write post to for it to
know that we're actually editing a post
and not not creating one and this here
I'll say this the ID equals post the ID
all right so now we know whenever the ID
is null that means we're in create mode
and if we have an ID that means we've
clicked edit and we this has been
triggered and we have an ID value right
here that means we're in editing mode so
we can use this ID property for this
conditional here so here we'll say if ID
like this as a ternary operator so if ID
is not know if it's truth e the value of
this will be update else the value of it
will be ad like this so JavaScript links
expression inside of string
interpolation
all right let's save and let's check if
that's working let's reload so now it's
add and if I click to edit this one it
says update cool
of course those labels don't go up about
whatever all right so now let's actually
make it so that it actually updates when
we sent to the server so here so on
submit when actually we need to say we
can't actually add the ID here and say
who calls this dot ID and it will still
work when we are creating a post because
in the post service if you remember here
in the post service if it checks if
postal ID and it's okay if we send this
idea if it's no and if it's not it's
still gonna send it to the post so that
would work just fine so nothing changes
here all right so let's save and let's
test this out all right let's say we
want to edit this edited and I just want
to add a bunch of these after this I
click update or
okay so that's not oh I see what's
happening
so because we didn't change the logic
this is actually edited but because our
logic in the in the home is just adding
those posts whenever received that
because if we if we refresh we get that
that post has been edited and it wasn't
actually added as a new one so what we
need to do so in the home view or is it
oh boy oh yeah here we need to check if
we already have that post we just edit
that post so I'm gonna cut this and
we'll say if this dot posts dot find
find and we need to pass this a
condition so a P or post where post dot
ID equals post dot ID of this post right
here so if this is true that means we
have this post so we need to find this
post so we need to find the index of the
post and replace the replace the element
at the index so we'll say constant index
equals this top post dot find index and
the the callback or the this thing is
post where postal ID equals post dot ID
and now that we have the index we can
just say this dot posts dot splice and
the way splice works is that give it a
start index and the start index will be
this index and you give it the number of
posts to remove which was just one we
just want to remove that and the third
one will be what you wanted to replace
it with we want to replace it by this
post that we got passed here else that
means else if we don't have this post in
that array that means this post is a new
one so we just pasted back that thing
that we say this post and shift so let's
save now let's reload here and now if we
add a new post it actually adds it right
here but if we edit an existing post
let's say I want to edit this and
instead of learned via I want to say
learn bridge is we say update it
actually updates this and it doesn't add
it cool so
our application is complete so yeah or
actually wait I want to format this I
want to format this because this doesn't
look good um how do we do this yeah
let's actually add a filter oh this is
another feature that I forgot to mention
there's this thing called filters what
we need to do is here we can write here
in here we can add a JavaScript
expression to to edit this but that's
not efficient because the markup would
look a bit crowded so here we'll add
this pipe character I used to call wall
but now I know it's called pipe and this
is similar to angular pipes and here
we'll say we'll call this pipe format
date and now we need to create this
filter and it will be applied to this so
here in the filters array or object
let's create this format date filter so
say format date and it will take date I
can name this whatever it's just an
argument and here we'll say I want to
change the date because right now is
just a string I want to form a date from
it we'll say new date and we'll pass it
this date and now this is an actual
JavaScript date object and I want to
format it that it will have the day the
month in the year I don't want to go
further because actually later on you
use something like moment or dangerous
but let's I want to do this without any
library so we'll say day equals date dot
get date date which will give us the
number of the day and here we'll have
the month
oops month equals date dot get month and
here we'll have a year which will be
date don't get full oops for yeah here
like this and here we'll say return
curly brace I mean
backticks they - or - month and - yeah
and if you're from America you can flip
this but the month at the beginning this
is like European format and now it will
here in this filter it will take this
and then process it with that filter and
return and put in the markup this result
all right so let's save so for example
let's look at this one this is the 13th
of oh it's already formatted alright
cool
yeah let's make sure that that's the
correct date so we can go to our view
where is it view right here go to our
data so here in the home in the post
she's not in the post form in the home
see our data the first post right here
all right here it's the it's indeed it's
the 13th of May of 2019
wait wait a second this is oh wait I
forgot month actually starts from 0 to
11 instead of 1 to 12 so let's say here
+1 and that should fix it and we say
when we go back here yeah there we go so
now it's actually the 13th of May of
2019 right here all right so that's it
for this tutorial I hope you enjoyed it
I hope you learn from it if you are a
beginner and you're like trying to
figure out which framework to learn view
is definitely for you I'll put a link of
the github repository including all this
code in the description and please let
me know if you like this video and if
you have any praise or criticism or
whatever and if you like this video like
it if you love this type of content
please subscribe and hit the like button
I mean the Bell button so you don't miss
any videos from me thank you very much
and I hope to see you soon bye